my last Instagram post spoke about
family businesses and talked about the
kids coming up this one's for the
parents with the kids that are coming up
so this one we talked about kind of some
of the common mistakes that the
youngsters come in with entitlement on
the flip side I am stunned by how many
parents don't give their kids the room
to fail their fear of the short-term
economics [ __ ] them up they're scared
of the quick loss of sale or an unhappy
customer but they're not giving the
breathing room for the kids to actually
make the mistake or more importantly
what if the kid is actually right and
it's actually bringing a tremendous idea
or innovation to the business this
control Factor this this this fear is
holding back a lot of parents from
giving their kids a huge opportunity to
innovate and maybe grow the business and
more importantly is showing their kid
that there isn't opportunity sometimes
losing the kid outright as the kid goes
on to do their own thing so for the
parents that are holding on too tight
let a little Breathing Room happen it
may win